I want to take some time today to really
go through yesterday's Trump rally in
Pennsylvania not because Donald Trump
did anything particularly more unhinged
than normal it was filled with all of
the stuff that has unfortunately become
normal in presidential rallies in the
Trump era but the reason that I want to
go through it in a little more detail
than we normally might is because of its
sociological value how it gives us
insight and understanding into what is
happening in the world of trumpets that
exists which I'll be perfectly honest as
someone who lives in Boston and only
occasionally travels to you know rural
Missouri or these types of places where
we have a bigger concentration of
trumpets and the ideology and cult of
personality that's been developed there
I think it's important for us not to
understand what's going on and to
realize that only through realizing how
it all works can we actually develop a
strategy that might work to remove
Donald Trump it's really important for
us to understand that this is a large
contingent of the country here in Boston
you know it's very left-wing and even
the right-wingers that there are are
more Romney ish right-wingers although
there's everything of course I don't
want to general generalize but to some
degree I have to generalize we are
talking here about tens of millions of
people who in my sense a big portion of
whom could vote again for Donald Trump
in 2020 we're talking about 60 million
people in 2016
whose connection to reality and facts
and reason and decency has been severed
by this presidency you will notice that
the Trump rally as an institution of
society has now become reminiscent of
the rallies of the great authoritarians
of the 20th and 21st early 21st century
now I'm not calling from Hitler stop
with the childish stuff what I am saying
is that these rallies over the decades
from authoritarian strongmen and
particularly ignorant authoritarian
strongmen start to take on a similar
feel and characteristic no dissenting
voices are allowed the audience must be
completely united fervently behind
whatever the strongman says with no
assessment of the
of what the strongman says the
atmosphere has to be both sort of jovial
but constantly on the verge of becoming
violent as well if the wrong thing is
said or if the wrong person appears
reverential towards the Dear Leader
no matter what they say absolute and
total lies stated as truth and cheered
by the audience as if they are truth an
unsafe place for any kind of difference
of opinion a place where everyone is
constantly judging evaluating and
monitoring the level of commitment of
those around them to the strongman that
is ranting on the stage anyway this one
in Pennsylvania at yesterday was really
out of control let's look at a few
moments this was one of trumps ugliest
and most sickening performances in a
very long time the more the walls closed
in the more erratic and authoritarian he
becomes here is Trump repeating the lie
that we weren't respected under Obama
but now we are I say it I've already
said it twice tonight this country is so
respected and we were not respected four
years ago we were laughed at
of course the truth is the opposite the
UN literally laughing at Trump during
his latest UN speech the world leaders
last week at the NATO summit literally
laughing at Donald Trump we are now a
laughingstock we weren't then but facts
don't matter Trump later claiming that
his bogus trade war is helping people
when it has done a lot of damage
including in the state of Pennsylvania
which we will discuss I've taken the
toughest ever action against China's
trade abuses they want to make a deal so
badly and we're doing well with the deal
but they want to make a deal please make
a deal we don't want to pay tariffs
anymore please please thanks to our
steel towers steel mills in Pennsylvania
are roaring back to life and US Steel
has just announced a 1 billion dollar
investment in Mon Valley works in
Pittsburgh you know that right
everything is the opposite no one in the
crowd has any clue what Donald Trump is
talking about and then Trump tells the
crowd that they have had their best year
ever he tells the Pennsylvania crowd
that Pennsylvania has had its best year
ever in Pennsylvania you had the single
best year that you've ever had in the
history of our country not bad now this
is not only wrong it's meaningless in a
sense like what does it mean that a
state had its best year ever
but the reality is that Pennsylvania
lost about a hundred of about 10,000
factory jobs Trump's own trade policy
has been crushing their steel industry
crushing their manufacturing industries
which are important industries in
Pennsylvania particularly you know
outside of Philadelphia outside some of
the biggest cities at one point during
the rally a female protester with a pink
sign said I had a pink sign that said
grabbing power back this is a reference
of course to Trump talking about
grabbing women by the the sign saying
we're gonna grab power back the crowd
noticed her started booing Trump said
get her out they threw her out very
quickly the crowd will turn on you at
these rallies yesterday the Justice
Department's inspector general released
a report detailing
the outrageous scandalous and
unprecedented abuses of power
[Applause]
get her out get around
Trump of course attacking impeachment
calling everything disgusting and a
fraud
now that the Russia witch-hunt is dead a
big fat disgusting fraud the
congressional Democrats are pushing the
impeachment witch-hunt
having to do with Ukraine
[Music]
but that's already family you saw their
so-called articles of impeachment today
people are saying they're not even a
crime what happened all of these
horrible things remember bribery and
this and that occur where are they they
send these two things are not even a
crime Trump then combining their two
most common defenses in one go which is
this didn't happen and this isn't a
crime it did happen but it's not a crime
the crowd doesn't realize it or they
don't care Donald Trump very often will
do this he will say oh this thing that
they're saying I did I definitely didn't
do it and by the way legal experts he'll
often quote people like Mark Levin and
Greg Garrett from Fox News legal experts
say there's no crime there's no crack
wait so hold on did you not do it or did
you do it but there's no crime it
doesn't matter
Trump then galvanizing anger against the
media in general
another common authoritarian technique
of uniting the crowd angrily against any
attempted check on the lies and the
wrongdoing of the strongman and Trump
going after the dishonest corrupt media
I always have to say this you have some
really great journalists and you have
some honest publications but not too
many of them I have to be honest with
you the legislature well you know that
does anybody think the media is honest
does anybody think they're totally
corrupt and dishonest and then Donald
from calling the FBI scum that's a nice
one right referring to top-level cops
and dirty players who are leaving
referring to intelligence officials
people at the FBI so on and so forth and
if you look at what's happened with the
scum that's leaving the very top of
government people that others used to
say oh that's one that dirty these were
dirty cops
these were dirty players
you take a look at what's going on
there's 21 of them already and I'm not
even doing they're just leaving because
they got caught like nobody ever got
caught
now at one point it actually goes beyond
parody Trump has ignored the
constitutional oversight mechanisms that
the house has ignoring subpoenas to
people that work for him directing
people not to testify violating the
emoluments clause endlessly and he
closes the rally with we support protect
and defend the Constitution which is
sometimes a meaningless bit of drivel
that we hear from elected officials but
with Trump it happens to also be
extremely opposed to the truth
indistinguishable from parody take a
look and above all we will never stop
fighting for the sacred values that bind
us together as one America one great
country one America we support protect
and defend the Constitution of the
United States we stand with the
incredible heroes of law enforcement we
also have some video from interviews
with trumpets outside of the rally and
some of you may be eating as you listen
to the show or watch watch the show so I
don't want to spoil your appetite with
too much of this stuff but it won't come
as a surprise that the trumpets that are
interviewed they repeat the exact same
talking points often verbatim that have
been fed to them by the Dear Leader they
have no idea what's going on and I
actually feel feel more sad than angry
about this it's sad because if we talk
critical thinking if we talk philosophy
if we taught civics starting you know in
middle school a lot of this stuff a lot
of these people would never fall for
this stuff to begin with but listen to
how this guy repeats Trump's phrases
word for word in defending Donald Trump
do you start on it what gets me fired up
is the impeachment hoax okay
other issues jobs unemployment the
lowest black unemployment lowest women's
all those those things are all positives
but when you have such a hoax when we
all saw the Washington compost 19
minutes into his election into 2016 when
he was elected they said the impeachment
process is started now 19 minutes
are you kidding me and then all this
year and now they said they have the two
things they're gonna obstruction of
Congress not even obstruction of justice
but obstruction of Congress and abuse of
power
which that's a big joke because they
talk about quid pro quo I see the video
of Joe Biden saying if you don't fire
that prosecutor I'm leaving in six hours
you're not getting the billions up
that's on video and they say no he
didn't do anything and yet the president
asked the question no I'm not an I'm not
an English major but the president if
you read the transcript please read the
transcript he asked a question if you
would do me a favor do me a favor if so
he's giving the ball to the Ukrainian
president it's a combination of
weaponized ignorant red herrings
misunderstandings of the facts refers to
the transcript which of course we don't
have because they didn't release a
transcript they released a little
excerpt it's all word-for-word what
Trump gives them they repeat in
unwavering defense of the Dear Leader so
what's the takeaway the takeaways are we
still have a country that is a Western
democracy on paper and in principle but
for half of the country or almost half
of the country 40 percent of the country
the dynamics the feel the style it's
becoming what we see in authoritarian
strongman nations and it should scare
the hell out of us if it hasn't already
number two we can't win by talking sense
into those people we can't talk them
into voting for someone other than Trump
now I understand this is a rally these
are the rabid supporters who don't care
about the facts now sure the rally
crowds are crazier and whackier than the
people who just go to work and then they
consider themselves Republicans and
election day comes around and they might
vote for Donald Trump but in either case
we've got to focus on get out the vote
we have to galvanize our side because a
lot of these people are not reachable
and it is a waste of time
to try to convince them at the
individual level I don't think we should
do it I think we should work on get out
the vote voter registration preventing
voter suppression and foreign meddling
in the election
let me know what you think very
depressing leave a reply if you're
watching on YouTube send me a tweet at D
Pakman follow me by the way on Twitter
at D Pakman as well you know at some
point in time I've been sort of thinking
more and more one would hope that there
is going to be some accounting for or at
least just like the simple realization
that the President of the United States
is not acting like an innocent person
and is not acting like a stable person
and I mean even from the right even if
they will continue to defend him as they
know that well it would be great just to
get that acknowledgment or see them
acquiesce to that simple reality but
regardless of what you think about
Donald Trump's tax policy or what he's
doing on trade or whatever we are
increasingly noticing that the behavior
that is visible publicly is not normal
and the latest exhibit in this is that
Donald Trump burst on Twitter is the
best word I can think of for it tweeting
80 times yesterday including dozens
already by 11:30 a.m. Eastern Time
mostly about the FBI impeachment
disinformation and lies in a completely
uncontrolled and irrational way
mirroring the hypomanic behavior that
mental health professional dr. John
Gartner told us about last week we've
wondered about like what is the process
for Donald Trump tweeting because we
know that in some cases he will dictate
his tweets to someone in the next room
but when there's a dozen retweets in a
half-hour or when he is sending tweet
after tweet after tweet it doesn't seem
like that's happening via dictation to
someone in the next room over it seems
like this is actually Donald Trump on
his phone like a maniac just tweeting
and tweeting and retweeting now if I
were to summarize the 80 tweets for you
I it's difficult to do but I would
summarize them as a combination of
insults rumors attacks unsubstantiated
conspiracy theories and lies
maybe with some disinformation thrown in
there certainly not presidential in any
sense of the word however it is that you
describe it so let's start digging into
a little bit of what went on yesterday
by 11:30 a.m. yesterday morning Eastern
Time Donald Trump had already tweeted or
retweeted more than 30 times and it
continued all day reaching 80 tweets 80
tweets in a day I don't pretend to be
the busiest person in the world but I am
way too busy to tweet 80 times in a day
I have to find time to make three four
five tweets and retweets in combination
sometimes I don't even have the time
sometimes at 10 p.m. I might send one
retweet out with a comment because I'm
so busy that that's not even possible
and I'm not even really that busy this
is the President of the United States
and he tweeted 80 times yesterday now to
set up the stage for Donald Trump doing
this as you may know as you probably
have heard by now House Democrats have
unveiled two articles of impeachment
which are actually being debated right
now in the House Judiciary Committee as
we produce today's program and many of
the tweets really almost all of the
tweets are in some way related to that
other than the occasional tweet bragging
about this that or the other thing so
for example Donald Trump retweeting a
post about Democrats are running a
kangaroo court was which was posted by
bond bond Thor and Congressman Jody hice
which said how House Democrats run a
kangaroo court ignore the rules untrue
refused to recognize legitimate
objections untrue and this is how it
works
steamroll the minority and railroad
Donald Trump this entire impeachment has
been a farce without any semblance of
fairness for a minority or presidential
response so there are so many lies here
and so many distortions of course in
general this is not true in the sense
that House Democrats have followed the
rules that are in place some of those
rules were established by Republicans
they did the closed-door hearings
correctly they've done the public
hearings correctly this is a farce
generally speaking but what you really
need to understand here is that
one when Jody hice says they've done
this without a presidential response
Jerry Nadler invited Trump or whoever he
designates to participate in the
Judiciary Committee hearings they turned
it down and of course Republicans said
well the participation would not have
been fair because the majority oppresses
the minority do not fall for that okay
the question is have the rules been
followed because this game that they
play Democrats play it as well
okay whoever is in the minority in the
house doesn't control the agenda in the
house doesn't control the committees
that's how it works this is how the
system is designed and any time anything
is going on in the house of note you
will see the whoever is in the minority
party at the time say we are being
steamrolled by the majority this is not
the way checks and balances are supposed
to work this is so unfair so on and so
forth this is the way the game is set up
if it's unfair the entire system is
unfair all the time even when
Republicans as the majority have used
the rules to quote oppress the minority
change the rules many of which
Republicans established so this is how
they distort and low information people
or just you know I'm not saying that
preservative Lee people who are just
busy living their lives making ends meet
they will see something like well it's
true I mean Trump hasn't said anything
Trump's Trump has to tweet because he
can't go in and participate he's been
invited and he's turned it down his
lawyers have been invited
they've been directed not to go and of
course this entire idea of steamrolling
the minority is a tried-and-true
complaint that whoever is in the
minority position will will use here we
have an impeachment so the stakes are
high I understand but there is nothing
unique about these complaints okay
another retweet example and don't worry
I'm not going to go through all 80
tweets like this another retweet example
from congressman Lee Zeldin who tweeted
with this disgusting impeachment charade
I mean of course it's just it's just
impeachment it's a constitutionally
enshrined and outlined mechanism with
this disgusting impeachment charade
House Democrats have proven themselves
guilty of abuse of power and obstruction
Congress this is a new line from
Republicans last night I did a stream
when the House Judiciary was starting
the debate on impeachment debate
yesterday it was just five minute
opening statement after opening
statement this is now a line that they
are repeating which is the Democrats
handling of the impeachment inquiry is
actually the real wrongdoing that they
accused Donald Trump of now of course
it's not true the idea of Congress
obstructing Congress it's kind of a
weird concept in and of itself but more
importantly this is the normal
projection that we're used to seeing
Republicans do whatever they are accused
of they simply accuse the other side
Democrats Obama you know whoever of
doing that exact same thing Donald Trump
also retweeting all sorts of other
far-right figures there's one guy named
tom Fitton you can google him if you're
curious and many many others but it
wasn't just read tweets yesterday and
Donald Trump tweeting 80 times in one
day Trump also tweeting things himself
for example attacks on other public
officials riddled with lies quote shifty
Schiff a totally corrupt politician made
up a horrible and fraudulent statement
read it to Congress and said those words
came from me he got caught was very
embarrassed
yet nothing happened to him for
committing this fraud he'll eventually
have to answer for this I think the only
accurate thing in that tweet is the
correct spelling of Adam shifts last
name despite being called Adam shift by
many people his last name was correctly
spelled in the tweet and that's all I
can identify that is actually accurate
Schiff didn't make up a statement he
wasn't caught you know embarrassed this
is another calculated strategy from
Republicans which is go after Adam
Schiff
why isn't Adam Schiff here testifying at
the House Judiciary Committee we hear
that time and time again during the
Judiciary Committee hitting hearings of
course Schiff is on the Intelligence
Committee not the Judiciary Committee
when will shift testify well why would
Adam Schiff testify in this entire thing
this is another line that Republicans
and Trump and people around Trump have
been repeated where is Adam Schiff he's
missing he
show up he's lying he's fabricating
documents he should be investigated and
possibly punished I'm not going to
subject you to all 80 of Donald Trump's
tweets and retweets if you're so
inclined you can review them yourself
but the highlights are lies and
disinformation this is not the behavior
of an innocent person this is not the
comportment of a stable person blame
anyone but yourself for anything you can
think of and again 80 tweets in a day
including dozens by 11:30 in the morning
when you suspect someone uses uppers and
you see what appears to be a manic hyper
use of social media certainly once again
it raises those questions about what
exactly is going on with Donald Trump
what I hope people understand is that
this is how Trump has operated his
entire adult business career blame other
people shift responsibility to somebody
else buy or coerce your way out of
problems intimidate your way out of
problems pass the buck whenever possible
count on the justice system to work well
for you because you're rich and it
usually works very well for the rich
this time it's turning out to be a
little bit harder to get away with it
because Donald Trump is President of the
United States after all but he still
might get away with it and that's the
worst part of it eventually you know
when you look at the Hollywood movie the
spoiled brat who's mean and a bully
eventually gets held to account by the
little guy by society whatever
eventually the strong man has a downfall
and the underdog or the people or
whatever get their day right this is not
a screenplay this is real life and in
real life we have two justice systems
and Donald Trump may well end up getting
away with this the narcissistic spoiled
brat who in the movies in the great
American novel whatever right eventually
when you write the story they have
consequences they experience
consequences for what they do this is
not a movie our system is not a movie
it's designed to let the rich privileged
bullies do whatever they want
and very often get away with it so that
is the unfortunate reality that we are
dealing with right now let me know your
thoughts about all of this if you've
been watching the Judiciary Committee
debate about the impeachment articles I
am on twitter at D Pakman you can send
me a message there please follow me
there you can also if you're watching on
YouTube just leave a reply as a comment
remembering of course to like this video
as well we'll take a quick break we have
a lot to discuss today I'm glad you're
with us I have for you today some of the
absolutely strangest video so far of
Donald Trump's presidency and that is a
really high bar given that almost all
the video we have of Donald Trump has
been extraordinarily strange and bizarre
Donald Trump complained about the
flushing of toilets hmm
10 to 15 times and about certain light
bulbs that he doesn't like he talked
about toilets or maybe it sinks and
showers quote not getting any water none
of it made any sense it sort of seemed
like it was maybe an attempt at humor
but Trump really has no sense of humor
some of it seemed like thinly veiled
compliment a complaints rather about
energy efficiency standards that exist
including around light bulbs it was a
word salad to end all word salads it was
a three-star Michelin rated word salad
from Donald Trump let's take a look at
the video see if we can figure anything
out let's listen to this first one but
together we're defending the American
workers were using common sense we have
a situation where we're looking vers
strongly it sinks and showers and other
elements of bathrooms where you turn the
faucet on in areas where there's
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to see because you
could never handle it and you don't get
any water you turn on the faucet you
don't get any water they take a shower
and water comes dripping out this
clipping out very quietly tripping out
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once they end up using
more water so EPA is looking at that
very strongly and my suggestion you go
into a new building or a new house or
new home and they have standards only
you don't get water you can't you can't
wash your hands practically this so
little water comes out of the faucet and
the end result is you leave the faucet
on if it takes you much longer to wash
your hands you end up using the same
amount of water so we're looking at very
seriously and opening up the standard
and there may be some areas where we'll
go the other route desert areas but for
the most part you have many states where
they have so much water that it comes
down as cold rain we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and
elements of bathrooms they take a shower
and water drips people are flushing
toilets ten times what is Trump doing
that he's flushing a toilet ten to
fifteen times or that it sounds
reasonable or likely to him that's one
question that this raises may be one for
a different day how can any Trump
supporter see this stuff and see
strength or leadership or intelligence
or cunning or cleverness how I need
someone to explain it to me please
here's another clip about the light
bulbs and we're doing other things too
light bulb they got rid of the light
bulb that people got used to the new
bulb is many times more expensive and I
hate to say it it doesn't make you look
as good of course being a vain person
that's very important to me
gives you an orange look out of what an
orange
has anyone noticed it so we'll have to
change those bulbs and at least a couple
of rooms where I am and the White House
I saw some trumpet comments comments
online where they are just fully
convinced that this is all comedy like
it's all humor beyond just Trump doesn't
want to look orange that's true but the
toilets the showers it's all humour
according to some online Trump astons
if that's the case what's the joke like
what is the joke about flushing a toilet
ten to fifteen times it's like when
Trump said windmill windfarms cause
cancer and some supporters said oh that
was a joke that was comedy well like
what what's the joke what's the
punchline I don't understand how that
even qualifies as a joke this was the
line during the campaign you might
recall every outrageous thing that
Donald Trump said was defended either as
listen Trump's just telling it like it
is he's not being politically correct
you won't hear this from a lot of other
politicians but Trump is just telling it
like it is or the other explanation for
equally crazy comments was he doesn't
literally mean everything he says these
are jokes this is humor you've got to
stop taking it all so seriously because
Donald Trump isn't actually speaking
seriously well well is it which is it is
it that everything is a joke or that
everything is serious and it's a truth
that nobody else is willing to tell you
but in all seriousness assuming that
this does all relate to building codes
if we want to try to assess what policy
might this actually be related to it's
Trump saying he doesn't like all the
building cold codes and he wants to look
at getting rid of them this is another
attack on sustainability this is yet
another attempt to undo environmental
regulations at every opportunity even
because of this vague ridiculous people
are flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
confusion and that's the policy concern
that underlies this that we shouldn't
forget at every opportunity that there
is an opportunity to either undo an
environmental regulation or just undo
something that Barack Obama did because
that's also another priority it doesn't
apply in all of these cases they are
doing it and the list of things that the
next president will hope
we have to undo or redo as the as the
case may more accurate accurately be
stated he's a growing list and this
stuff matters I mean I know that you
know we've talked before Elizabeth
Warren she was asked during a recent
debate should the government get to tell
you what kind of light bulbs you use and
Elizabeth Warren astutely said that's
the wrong question a hundred companies
are responsible for seventy something
percent of all emissions in this country
the pollution the question of straw or I
think it was actually not about light
bulbs but maybe it was about straws the
issue of straws is not really the big
issue what we have here are much much
bigger issues to tackle they mostly
relate to industry but if you look at
the entire country's building and
construction engine industry and you
look at these guidelines and
environmental standards they do make a
difference in the aggregate and to laugh
them off or to pretend that the
government wants you to have a crappy
toilet that can't you know that Trump
needs to flush ten times because of
whatever he's doing or whatever the case
may be it's another one of these
distractions and it is yet another way
that the sort of bonus or priority for
dealing with the environmental
destruction is at the individual level
it's the toilet I choose it's the straw
that I choose when there are much bigger
issues and they're regulating there as
well I think it's important not to
forget bizarre video again just kooky
video but it does connect to serious
issues related to regulation and the
environment and climate change make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show make
sure you're also following me on
instagram at david pakman the big news
of the day is that Democrats in the
House of Representatives have announced
two articles of impeachment against
President Donald Trump it's happening
this is still merely the beginning even
though it feels like we are very far
into it including I mean we are dozens
and dozens of hours into live streams of
all sorts of different hearings but
still we are only now sort of getting to
the real meat of it this morning Nancy
Pelosi with an initial statement
followed by a Jerry Nadler chairman of
the House Judiciary Committee announcing
articles of
Pietschmann followed by Adam Schiff
chair of the House Intelligence
Committee detailing the evidence for
each of those two and this is going to
be a big battle and it's going to be a
political battle importantly as much as
it is going to be a battle around the
evidence two articles of impeachment
charging Donald Trump the first article
is for abuse of power the president
Democrats say exercising powers of
public office to obtain improper
personal benefit while ignoring or
injuring the national interest what does
that mean in practice well this is what
they say Donald Trump did when he
solicited and pressured Ukraine to
influence our election and thus it is
impeachable because it violates his oath
say Democrats this will be now
adjudicated in a Senate trial assuming
the house votes to go forward consistent
with previous invites that Donald Trump
made in 2016 it was noted noted by Jerry
Nadler although that is not actually
what Donald Trump is being impeached for
and that is going to be a question mark
which is when the impeachment hearings
started there were assertions that they
should have included the emoluments
clause they should have included Trump's
dealings with the Yemen Fiasco that they
should have included some of the
obstruction that the Moller report
indicated Donald Trump participated in
but they don't and that is going to be
part of Democrats the Republicans
defense we will get to that a little bit
later
now article two is obstruction of
Congress and that actually relates to
Donald Trump's reaction when Congress
started investigating article 1 when the
impeachment inquiry was started Donald
Trump Democrats say engaged in defiance
of the inquiry which leads to another
impeachment article obstruction of
Congress Democrats said today that
Donald Trump by his actions when the
inquiry was announced declared himself
above accountability that the American
people were subjugated by Donald Trump
as behavior that Donald Trump declared
himself above the impeached
and power of Congress which is a
constitutionally enshrined power and
that is count number two now Adam Schiff
explained what the evidence is and one
of the things I like about how Adam
Schiff is approaching this is that he
made it about the evidence tells us we
must impeach ignoring the political
sitter considerations now there are
political considerations and I'm going
to talk to them but I have said from the
beginning that calculating whether the
impeachment process is likely to succeed
or not or how it is likely to affect the
Democratic primary those are perfectly
reasonable things to discuss but when we
are talking about something as serious
and infrequently used as not the power
of impeachment but the duty of
impeachment when the facts warranted
there should not be political
considerations and we're going to get to
that now Adam Schiff continued to lay
out the evidence that they have during
this morning's announcement pointing out
that Donald Trump solicited Ukraine to
publicly announce investigations into a
political opponent or or an expected
political opponent Joe Biden in order to
help his own campaign this is an abuse
of the power of the office of the
presidency and that too specific
official acts were conditioned upon at
least the announcement of those
investigations number one the release of
military aid to Ukraine and number two a
White House meeting for the Ukrainian
president Adam Schiff said this
jeopardizes the integrity of the 2020
election it jeopardizes the integrity
and sovereignty of the United States to
run its own elections free from this
type of foreign meddling and Adam Schiff
claims to have overwhelming evidence of
all of this and then laying out the
evidence for count number two
obstruction of Congress that once the
news of the impeachment inquiry or
potential impeachment inquiry went
public that Donald Trump obstructed
Congress shift says he has all of the
evidence now one of the critiques all
along this entire thing this entire
inquiry and now the articles should
include Donald Trump's emoluments
violations emoluments Clause violations
I believe that that is absolutely
correct and it is too late for that now
and the attempt to
anything in now whether it's about 2016
interference other than merely providing
context or emoluments or whatever else
would be no question seized on by
Republicans to try to discredit the
entire thing saying look it was about
this and you said it was about this
initially and now you're pulling in
these other issues I think it would be
strategically a mistake
although politically there may be some
benefit to it Donald Trump immediately
starting to tweet including about the
u.s. MCA this trade deal that he's been
talking about for a while also upon
learning that Democrats would be
announcing this today just before the
hearing started Donald Trump tweeting to
impeach a president who has proven
through results including producing
perhaps the strongest economy in our
country's history to have one of the
most successful presidencies ever and
more importantly who has done nothing
wrong is sheer political madness hashtag
20/20 election now what's important to
understand about this is that Donald
Trump has refrained has continued to use
this refrain time and time again at
rallies during interviews etc which is
how do you impeach a president who's
doing just such a good job and that is
exactly the misunderstanding about
impeachment that Donald Trump and many
on the right seemed to have impeachment
is not about from the point of view of
Democrats can we is this going to help
us or hurt us in 2020 what's this going
to do to Bernie and Warren if it pulls
them off of the campaign trail to be at
a Senate trial it is not about that it
is about what do the facts say given
what impeachment is supposed to be for
on the same along the same lines but on
the other side is this idea from
trumpets and from Republicans that if
the stock market is doing well the
president shouldn't be impeached that is
not what this is about that was never
what impeachment was meant to before and
that the continued either
misunderstanding or disingenuous
deliberate misstatement about the
parameters of impeachment is tricking a
lot of Trumpets into parroting that line
the economy is doing really well how is
it that you can impeach a president well
the two things have nothing to do with
each other so now what well now the
Judiciary Committee of the house is
going to meet they will examine the
articles and they will make a
recommendation to the house eventually
the house will vote now there was a
report this morning that that vote would
happen on December 12th
that's just 48 hours from now I don't
know if that still is the plan Jerry
Nadler didn't mention it during his
speech anyway we will see then we would
move importantly that requires only a
50% plus one vote in the house to move
forward we would then be moving forward
to a Senate trial there is speculation
that that could be in January as of last
week the Senate's calendar for 2020
starts in February they left January
blank presumably to account for the
possibility of the impeachment trial and
that could lead to a Senate impeachment
trial of the President of the United
States that wraps up just before the
first twenty twenty Democratic primary
votes start being cast on February 3rd
in Iowa in the Iowa caucus and that's
where we start getting into the
political implications but it's
important to separate them we want to
separate the political implications and
possible repercussions of this
impeachment from the duty to do this
because the facts say that impeachment
is proper shift did this he explained we
won't get anywhere if we wait there were
arguments politically motivated
arguments about maybe it's better to
wait the timing could be better this
that the other time Adam Schiff pointed
out the White House has been ignoring
our requests it took months just to get
a court to say that Donald Trump's
attorney Don McGann must testify it's
still not clear that the guy is going to
testify if he does he's going to assert
executive privilege and or invoke his
Fifth Amendment right so that was well
said by Schiff saying let's wait is
saying let's let them maybe cheat again
in an election or let's let them cheat
one more time in an election and that
that doesn't make any sense
Adam Schiff rightly framing this as
we're defending the Constitution period
that's what we have to do
impeachment has happened only three
times before Andrew Johnson and Bill
Clinton both of
were acquitted in the trials in other
words with Andrew Johnson and Bill
Clinton the house said via of majority
vote simple majority let's go forward
there was a Senate trial and the Senate
voted to acquit you then had Richard
Nixon Richard Nixon resigned before the
Senate trial of course under the
assumption the overwhelming pressure
that he was under knowing that
Republicans were going to turn on him in
the Senate because Republican voters had
turned on him and he resigned to avoid
ultimately being convicted on
impeachment so there has never been an
impeachment conviction for a president
in the history of the United States
I don't expect there to be one this time
and we're going to get into that into
that we're gonna get to that in a second
the Senate trial which would be held
would be presided over by the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court John
Roberts and then you need 2/3 of the
Senate to vote to convict to remove the
President of the United States as of
right now and in January which will
still be the same Senate that means you
need 20 Republicans where does that math
come from there are forty-five Democrats
in the Senate there are two independents
Bernie Sanders and angus King who caucus
with the Democrats and would be expected
or at least for our math we should
assume they vote to impeach that's 47
you need 67 meaning you need 20
Republicans now in the most optimistic
case senator from Connecticut Chris
Murphy
said as I told you yesterday he knows of
maybe a handful of Republicans that
would consider it consider voting to
convict Donald Trump even if he's right
and you get five even if he gets twice
as many and he gets 10 you're still
short by 10 so I don't see this as
getting Trump out via a conviction but
it does appear to be the correct thing
to do simply because it's what the
evidence says needs to happen not
necessarily what's most politically
advantageous now that being said let's
get to the political implications it
could be good for Democrats it could be
bad for Democrats a Trump acquittal in
the Senate could completely reinvigorate
Trump and his followers who say he has
been vindicated after the rusher
probe and the impeachment hoax as they
are calling them and there may even be
some 2016 Trump voters who still on
paper support Trump but they're kind of
disillusioned and maybe they were
planning on staying home
it could really reinvigorate the pro
Trump electorate and it could rock it
Donald Trump to re-election in 2020
that's one possibility the other way it
could go is the Senate trial is
devastating to Donald Trump a couple of
Republicans do turn but not enough to
convict Donald Trump and it feels as
though this guy has again escaped the
consequences and a sense of justice
makes people invigorated to go out and
vote for somebody else that could also
happen I'm not feeling like it's hugely
likely the Republican response and
strategy we already know is an effective
one which is attack the entire thing is
a pre-planned farce Democrats decided
back in 2017 they were going to do this
there's no evidence the real story is
hunter bite and they will say it was all
hearsay which of course is both untrue
and misunderstands that hearsay is a
type of evidence remember these are not
criminal proceedings so that is a red
herring but those have been effective
strategies so far last thing political
implications for Democrats there's an
idea floating around that impeachment in
total like from the get-go impeachment
is an establishment Democratic strategy
to deny Bernie or Warren their
nominations possible nominations as the
Democratic nominees the story being the
Senate trial is going to pull Bernie and
Warren off of the campaign trail at
exactly the right time it'll tie them up
and it will get Joe Biden more attention
it will leave Joe and Pete Budaj and
other establishment candidates out there
by themselves without Bernie or Warren I
don't think that that would work number
one since Bernie and Warren being part
of the trial would get them likely lots
of free TV time that could help them
number two the trial is likely to happen
in the few weeks leading up to the first
caucus in Iowa and then they will again
be free to go and campaign as we
approach Super Tuesday in all of those
other days so I just don't think if that
is the strategy I think it's a pretty
poor strategy to deny Bernie and Warren
the nomination a lot here a lot going on
let me know your thoughts leave a reply
if you're watching on YouTube of course
after liking this video otherwise send
me a tweet at D Pakman follow me on
Twitter a lot of this discussion
happening there